hello and welcome to hot see a
collaboration between sky news and first
news the UK's national newspaper for
young people hot seat has already seen
some of the country's most powerful men
and women questioned by young people
about the issues that matter to them
we've seen the Chancellor of the
Exchequer refused to take on a times
table test an education secretary
defending a parent's right to a mild
smack and today we are very pleased that
the London Mayor Boris Johnson has
agreed to take the hot seat well thank
you thank you thank you now let me tell
you who you're up against this is the
hot seat panel they've been drawn from
first news readers and from stand up be
counted Sky News campaign to get young
people engaged in politics we have an
echad ray Robert eben erst at Charlotte
Corrigan Beatrice Bannister Nathan
Farrington and Sofia hindmarsh now
before they get started let's get mr.
Johnson to introduce himself and explain
just what is it that makes you so
important to their lives white an honor
to be invited on this show i'm the i'm
boris house I'm the mayor of london and
i don't know do any of you live in
london okay well in that case I run the
the buses and the tubes which you have
free transport on by the way and I do
all I have to look up to the police and
fire and housing and loads of stuff like
that so I'm responsible for the economic
progress of London in all sorts of ways
trying to make sure that there are jobs
how about that lazy man yeah that'll do
okay let's get started first up is
Aniyah would you like to become Prime
Minister and if so what is the Boris
factor straighten their good God well
there's I want David Cameron to be Prime
Minister and he's doing brilliantly and
I think he will be reelected in a few
weeks time because I think he's helped
to turn the economy around in a very big
way things are going very good but very
well for our country now you'll see a
lot of growth jobs are being created at
a rate we haven't seen for a long long
time and young people are getting into
work in a way that we hadn't seen for
about 25 years so I think Dave is going
to get back in and I think it's more
likely frankly that one of you
we'll take over from some dillion some
dim distant future then I will and the
Boris factor what is it well I search
him search miga I me neither well i
think you know i was lucky to get
elected in in 2008 i think most london i
was even more lucky to get reelected in
2012 and then to help do the the
olympics and god only knows i know i I
suppose it's just a question of doing
your best turn turning up is a is a is a
very important thing always turn up my
strong advice to you turning up is about
ninety percent of success in life
certainly not funny are you happy with
that I'm yeah Frank okay Robert you've
got a question if you could take any
famous landmark from another country and
place it in London which would it be and
why but I've got your proposal to do
exactly that I don't know if you ever
been to Washington they had in
Washington some of the most fantastic
museums in the world the errands coming
to the Air and Space Museum in
Washington where you can see the
rockettes that went to the moon you can
see the the Apollo space rockets the
machines they were in it's called the
Smithsonian and we are going to take it
over sorry we're going to build in
London the first Smithsonian outside
america so it's going to be a branch of
that of that museum in the Olympic Park
in in Stratford and it will be a
fantastic thing for that part of London
it will attract loads and loads of
people from around around the world and
I hope it will be a great thing for kids
growing up in in that part of London
Robert do you have a building you'd
bring her yeah which was that what about
the word about the would you bring the
Eiffel Tower probably bring the either
the Great Wall of China well you see you
know but we got a bad reputation in this
country for bringing things because we
if you remember we've got Cape atras
needle on the embankment which we took
from Karnak or thieves or somewhere
gotta stop state and we took we took
large quantities of the building called
the Parthenon from Athens we took
remember we took the what's called the
Elgin marbles
and and they want them back so so I
think we're gonna actually I don't want
to give them back but I don't I don't
wanna I don't want to take any more
buildings from from elsewhere tragic
though I would point out by the way if
you see what's happening now in in Syria
where those port those deluded demented
guys are smashing those statues it's
quite a good thing that so many of them
are in the British Museum rather than in
Syria now I just putting that out there
Charlotte you next you fought with a
Chinese dragon and you got stuck on a
zip player do you think you are
interesting than Ed Miliband and David
Cameron and why do you think so many
politicians are boring yeah well I want
you to know that being stuck on the zip
wire was actually far more painful than
you can and it lasted much longer than
you think it took ages to find a rope so
that they could pull me towards the the
thing at the end and I this was during
the Olympics and I didn't have anybody
but I didn't have anybody to tell me he
said that I had a bodyguard which I
don't normally have but they decided to
be so embarrassing if I if I came to
grieve during the Olympics that they
gave me Tony Blair's ex-bodyguard it was
a very nice guy called Col Col and after
I've been stuck on the on the on the zip
while in some embarrassment and personal
discomfort sure for you know I for about
five minutes i said to carl is there
anything you can do and he very we're
like this and you very slowly took out
his mobile phone he took a photograph of
my my rear end that was what he did so
that was that was the most he he
achieved in that on that paper episode
anyway so Carl was enjoying your
discomfort but you are missing part of
the question are you more interesting
than EDD Miliband and David Cameron yeah
I you know I make no comment on on the
on the leader of the Opposition who
misses you obviously misspent hotel but
David Cameron is going to go forward to
I hope very much go forward to victory
in the next few weeks and I think he's
doing a very good job and I think the
he's very very competent and expert
leader of the of the country and he's
somebody who I think Phil's the job of
Prime Minister very well and I think he
should continue to do that safe in the
obtained an interesting way in an
interesting way great we've also had a
great response from young people so
let's take our first video question now
starting with Kira who is stand up be
counted contributor I'm Kira from
Liverpool and 5.3 million people living
less than the living wage yak and peas
are seeking fair the jobs because
they're 69 grand plus salary a year is
not enough for them do you think that an
MP salary is enough m and do you think
that mmm PS now just arm represent in
working-class people 67,000 pounds is it
and I certainly think that MPs should
not be going around trying to take more
dosh off the the taxpayer I think that
public service is is a is a privilege
and it's a great thing to be able to do
i'm hoping also to be elected to
parliament in in may i think by the way
you are question are talked about the
living wage i think that is a fine fine
thing the living wage and we've been
championing it tonight i don't know
whether you know what the living wages
or how it works it's not compulsory so
you're not forcing firms to pay it
you're simply pointing out to them that
where they can pay a little bit more to
some of their lowest paid employees that
is a great thing to do and it works for
them so you give them justice just for
the people at the bottom just a little
bit more and it doesn't mean that the
whole firm goes bust because they're
very rich firms and we've seen a big
increase the number of firms in London
who paid and it's put about 60 million
pounds into the pockets and some of the
hardest working people in in London so
to the living wages I think a great
thing to do so speaking about people
higher up the income salary MPs do you
think they should be able to take
private jobs and do you think you'll be
able to be both mayor and MP at once I
think that yeah I'm going to have to do
do combine both things for about a year
exactly
from from a tree if I'm lucky enough to
get in in May this year I'm gonna have
to do it from mater to me and the only
reason I think that's okay is because
well it's been done before I did it
before which I was both an MP and and
there for a while my predecessor was
emptying and therefore it for ages I
think basically it's like if you're if
you're running a big government
department if your if your secretary of
state for for whatever it is for defense
or health or something then you have a
huge responsibility plus you're also an
MP so i would i would do better private
consultancy you know I not as not as I
minister cause you know you can do that
okay let's go back to this panel and
fitter asst has a question if you could
change one thing about the world now
instantly without having to pass it
under any law what would it be I would
change the thing where all these kids
these pork these young people in London
and in other places are getting sucked
into this jihadi nonsense I don't know
whether you've seen what's happened with
these these young girls going from
London schools young men learning all
this absolute rubbish it's nothing to do
with Islam properly understood we need
to knock it on the head how about you
just just change their mindset so that
they see this as a catastrophic mistaken
of a false tourney ok I think Nathan
this is something you wanted to talk
about as well yeah and again terrorism
is rising but people leaving the UK to
join the ISIS so what will you do to
stop this and should we feel safe in the
UK we should feel safe in the UK and
this is a very very safe society the
police do a wonderful job of keeping us
I think crime is is done the rates are
down this is an increasingly safe safe
city but you're so right Nathan we do
have a problem with with with terrorism
and with young people who are just being
driven I think in my view off the edge
by an ideology that is very seductive
but its leading them into terrible
disease
astris mistakes and criminal behavior so
you need to see what they're doing and
I'm afraid you need to be able to
monitor them and I don't I think when
they're communicating with each other
over the Internet we should be able to
see that place and security services
should be able to see what they're doing
and meeting on social media Amy I
including on Facebook or Twitter or
whatever whatever I'm not agree let's
bet on social media but they should they
should they should definitely have that
that power and when they come back to
Britain they should be all they should
be arrested there's no question okay
great Sofia you are a very popular mayor
of london you've introduced the oyster
cards the Boris bike starts a very
useful you find alcohol and sports and
you've represented London all around the
world you also have a really cool hairdo
so why be an MP ah alright well I have
done an awful lot of those things I
think I am I I am blushing i do easter
card i gotta admit to you the oyster
Carly let's brilliant we've massively
expanded in fact you've got bank card
you can pay with your back if you have a
bank card in the vehicle bank on open up
probably not quite right dead bother you
can pay by the way but you in a few
years time you'll be able to pay with
your mobile phone whether you will just
you'll just you'll just you'll just wave
your mobile phone if you have a mobile
phone you have a moment know what you're
doing it if you will where your mobile
phone at the and in the future you'll
probably have you probably have that
you'll probably have your little rice
sized or smaller microchips embedded in
your list you just blink you can just
wait and you and you'll invisibly pay
that way so the technology is changing
the whole time awesome question well I'm
going to be because it's I think to be
given the responsibility of serving a
constituency to be trying to do your
best for people in uxbridge and south
ruislip is where I'm I'm trying for is a
fantastic privilege I think there's a
lot of rubbish talk to the moment about
how everybody thinks MPs are twerps and
so on I don't agree I don't agree i
think most people actually understand
the MPs are vital
that they do on the whole good job most
of them are incredibly hard-working and
yes some of them do let the side down
and youth and we've seen some recent
stuff about people see me too on too
much money or rest of it but most of
them it really aren't like that and i
think the House of Commons British
democracy is absolutely wonderful and
something that is respected still added
mod around the world so I'm I'm quinta
to get back in there okay you heard it
here first and peas are not twerps now
let's hear not all work and more then
maybe some selfie yes not all 12 may not
all sweat sorry right more selfie
questions from our stand up be counted
contributors hello my name is angel and
my question for Bruce Johnson is what is
he going to do to make sure that
youngsters outside the capital
concealing opportunities are available
in South Capitol to young people so
things like apprenticeships internships
where he experienced that perhaps we
wouldn't get in smaller cities outside
of the capital hello Boris my name's
puzzle and I come from grief at high
school my question is how would you
prove to your Conservative Party
followers that the policies that you've
been implementing are as met as the
mayor of london are truly conservative
values and ideologies I'm dumb I'm 16
from Keynes I would like to know where
is your current opinion on immigration
and its potential policy changes ok
great ok I can remind you yeah it's
outside the first question was about to
apprenticeships and how can kids outside
London understand the opportunities get
on our website if you think that you if
you living outside on who's who's from
London who's outside London sorry yep
yeah where you step I'm from London
London London ok just a couple morning
you could just get on with our websites
look at the apprenticeship schemes that
that's where we get our policies
conservative in the sense that they have
been about trying to deliver better
value services for less money for
everybody yes they are and we've cut the
council tax in in London year after year
and we're going to keep cutting it and
the previous guys who weren't
conservative by the way
the left-wing chap who was in before me
he whacked council tax up by one hundred
and fifty three percent so and we're
going to cut it in real terms by twenty
percent so that's where he's gone but
that was that a conservative image and
on immigration I think there is there's
two slice of it I think that I'm I don't
want to be hostile to immigrants I think
immigrants London has a population forty
percent almost 40% were born abroad and
they are hugely contributing to the
dynamism of the economy well I don't
want to see is people come in coming in
illegally and I don't want to see people
bludging and skiving and idling and
loafing and leaching and think of
another word like that off of the state
generator inside yeah and so I think we
need to watch out for that I think what
David Cameron is proposing on on that in
that area is is very sensible so make
sure the controls are tight you know
Britain's a wonderful place to be it's a
privilege it's a huge privilege to be
able to live here control the people
coming in don't let them milk the system
but don't be hostile to somebody just
because they've made the decision to
uproot themselves and come and build a
life in another country because they
will be people very often of a great
deal of energy and talent and my own
ancestors came from abroad I had a
Turkish great-grandfather who came to
this country in the early part of the
20th century and if Britain had in
London hadn't taken him in well I
certainly wouldn't be here he did he
then went back to Turkey of courting you
and got killed but there he brought was
because he was a he wasn't a very
successful politician I'm afraid to say
okay thank you back to our panel and
Aniyah what's your biggest regret in
your political and personal life Jesus
regret my single I'm Leslie I think but
i think what does just this
I think I regret bitterly I still regret
my failure to get anywhere as a as a as
a rock star player of the of the guitar
I I tried at school too to master the
guitar with a view to becoming a famous
you know hate it exactly and and it was
hopeless and I thought right well I
mastered the piano and that went even
worse oh that's my real my real so I
would if you do have any the slightest
musical ability if anybody has a
sighting me then you know keep going i
would encourage people with any talent
whatever not to not to waste it because
i frankly had none and you know it's
painful to see people who do have time
to waste it so that's personal political
just didn't think I me think yeah i'll
tell you one i think that in 2003 I was
naive and unrealistic about my
expectations of the level of planning
that we had done for the aftermath of
the Gulf War of the removal of Saddam
Hussein I thought that the Pentagon must
have worked out a way forward I thought
that actually if we were going to kick
this tyrant out we had worked out away
in which a new government would come in
a new society would be organized and how
that and how power would be transferred
the tragedy was there was no transfer of
power to anybody was it was more or less
anarchic and and it was one of the
reasons we've now got the shambles in in
Iraq and and Syria that you see today so
I suddenly regret that okay thank you
Robert do you have a crush on any
celebrities if so who dad so that's a
really difficult you bowling these right
on middle stump yeah I you know I just I
had to be very careful what I say I have
anything i have previously admitted to
two
it's too embarrassing it's too
embarrassing not an issue i guess i
strike i can't i'm taking a 5th
amendment on this basil brush how about
that if you did come to go on a date
with battle brush I think you might want
to brush your hair so here's a code oh
thank you there you go thank you very
much thank you i'm not gonna comb it now
thank you very much before you see basil
all right Charlotte you're next do you
agree with Ed Miliband that tuition fees
should be cooked no i don't i don't
agree with that policy i think that the
what they're what labor are proposing
would be absolutely disastrous for
university finance we've got some of the
best universities in the world here in
in london and the four of the top 10
universities they depend on they depend
on being properly financed are the best
people to contribute to the financing of
those universities are the students who
benefit from over their lifetimes
graduates from universities will
massively more than people who don't go
to university so i'd rather see them
subsidize the universities and general
taxpayers who don't benefit from that
from that education so i'm not i'm not a
taker for that policy at all ok
fantastic but you did a course benefit
from free education yes i did i did and
but you know that was a that was at a
time Anushka when a much smaller
proportion of the population went to
university we've hugely expanded higher
education provision in this country
rightly because it's a great thing but
it needs to be paid for who's going to
pay for it should it be everybody
including people on lots of people on
very low incomes or should it be the
university graduates who are in a much
stronger financial position as a result
of their education I got a left-wing
defense over tuition fees Beatrice and
what sort of dad you do you embarrass
your children you've got to ask you've
got to ask them and I think that
yeah you know a thing it would be I'd be
embarrassing them even more if I were to
attempt to answer that question we can
answer the first part what sort of dad
are you embarrassing problem and
embarrassing how do you remember I'd
burn Barisan Nathan obesity in the UK
has become a big problem with
sixty-seven percent of men and
fifty-seven percent of women being
overweight or obese how will you reduce
this amount particularly in children
well we we are trying to do all sort of
things in London to help with that
problem it is it is pretty bad but it's
getting a little bit better would you
believe it London kids are getting a
little bit lighter I and that is that is
good news we're trying to help with all
sorts of exercise programs through
supporting walking cycling sport we have
a huge grassroots sport operation trying
to get kids involved in in sport we're
trying to encourage healthy eating in
schools we've got stuff in the London
plant we've got stuff to discourage
councils from giving permission to
chicken fast-food joints and greasy you
know foods shops being set up right next
to schools now let me ask you do you
prefer if you had the choice at lunch
between pizza and chips and trying to
fix something I can tell you're gone
most of all vegetables it chicken pizza
and chips and and veg and a lovely
lovely ratatouille with a lovely
vegetable ratatouille with salad which
would you rather have holy the pizza
yeah that's the problem you think
restrict choices but isn't that a bit
nanny state I think I think you got to
encourage kids to be helpful to some or
other do you eat healthily would you
have chosen the peaks or other you on
the other I would have bred both hit the
tragic consonant
great Sofia you know you are very good
at Latin so what does princeps se valam
mean well it I I know what you're trying
to get valo David Cameron em SE pretty
pet Oh beautiful what does that mean I
want David Cameron to be Prime Minister
day again not forever but for as long
okay you can tell us what does it really
mean I think it I want to be leader have
a little question any question yeah but
right quickly last to Nathan then Sofia
what makes you angry I noticed that you
went to the east coast of America were
you given any gifts or souvenirs what is
the most unusual gift that you have ever
been given son usual gift oh let me
think you must have had a few yeah yeah
yeah yeah no absolutely I just trying to
think I i think when i was it when i was
in that when i was in the Gulf I was I
was art we had a they laid on a banquet
for us and I was asked to we had to eat
camel which I thought was pretty very
evening at can't resist i want one bite
at a time basically and it was it was it
does it taste like it's rather good
taste Robert a strong like a mutton it
tastes like a big sheet a big shaking
shaking and what makes you angry um I
think very very little is the truth
except possibly being beaten at tennis
by all any other game by one of my
brothers and sisters where but I don't
get really angry before I don't
encourage anybody get angry no we're
just about losing again so you're not an
angry man
oh no I mean if I think well if people
one thing I do object it I i have a very
anomaly Iver I don't have a but when
people went when lorry drivers come up
behind me and I'm just cycling
innocently in the middle of the road now
I'm keeping to my side of the road and
they decide that because they're so big
and there Lawrie is so powerful and they
want to just clear me out of the road
and they hoot aggressively then I do see
read a bit I do and I and I sometimes
when the traffic lights if I draw next
to them I won't give them a piece of my
mind well bet you have as much as as
such as it is yeah I do love to see that
thank you very much that is it for this
edition of hot seat I would like to
thank our panel and to all those who
sent in their questions and thanks of
course to the london mayor boris johnson
perhaps next time he's in the hot seat
he'll be an MP or maybe an even higher
office let's see thank you